so by the time this comes out this would
have been very old by now but we haven't
really got a chance to have
had a real debrief on our cycling
special oh yeah
um because we we filmed an outro and
that turned out to be 26 minutes or
something like that and we were just
like
yeah originally people we were like
people don't want to hear us talk about
a special thing
by the way if you haven't watched the
cycling special you should go and do
that before we
we're going to talk he's talking about
that video so if you want to watch that
link down below or
on screen now but um i think the biggest
thing i mean obviously the reaction for
that has been absolutely
incredible but what i found funny was
how seriously people took when it came
to
discussing who won and who lost and who
cheated
in that cycling special there was i've
never seen
like our subreddit turn into like just
the most like
no you don't it was a [ __ ]
free-for-all for a good
for a good period of time there it was
it was like it was like a [ __ ] like
team guard
and joey versus connor battle is this
how the twilight fandom were in their
prime
yeah i mean i get it you know they
they're they're invested
they're investing which is a good sign
which is a good sign yeah yeah but i
mean okay i think i
i'm very like i'm very fake salty like
i'm always like fake
i think we are all fake salty and fake
but like in real life as well i'll get
like i'll start like getting like i'll
sound like loud i'm like yo this is
[ __ ] up and then i'll be like well you
you really can't like no no no i
remember i just like getting annoyed
about things
in a way that isn't like that's very
twitter
i mean like you know the chili i was
like at the moment i'm sure
when i found out you cheated i was like
[ __ ] and then i probably just
thought like
all right yeah yeah yeah but then
obviously because there's also clips of
like me talking about on my live stream
but obviously like i play up the
saltiness because i have you know it's
good showmanship you know it is
it's funny but it's unfortunate that
like a large majority of the internet
doesn't understand sarcasm there was
so i there was a there was a like enough
subreddit people discussing
yeah who cheated who really won the real
world who done it
and there was this one comment i can't
remember where it was called but they
were like it was like
big man connor cahoon thinks he's a real
winner
real chad huh calling his friends
cheetahs when he cheated
he was getting so angry about it and i
was like what the [ __ ]
it was just so funny seeing how like the
fact that
there were so many people who are
infinitely more saltier than we are like
we didn't give a [ __ ] it's like to us
it's you know we make the video we film
it yeah yeah if someone cheats you know
it's
and it makes for good content it makes
for good content yeah i mean originally
i remember going on a cycling special i
i think i i
this let's go cut out the uh video but i
remember telling connor
yeah i'm going to do the whole thing
because you know you know
if i don't even if i don't win i'll feel
good if i do the whole thing yeah and
so the fourth challenge happened and
then joey
suggested the cheating and i just
thought to myself that'll make for a
really funny segment if we do actually
that's exactly what it was it's like
yeah you know saying that oh
i wanted to take a [ __ ] free car ride
like you know i'd be lying if i say i
didn't want that
but ultimately i was like no no no let's
do this because it'll make for great
content and it did it's yeah it's not
about the race it was about
friendship it was it wasn't about it it
was about the friends we lost along the
way
which is apparently each other
no because like i i feel like you know
it's there's there's a difference
between
obviously none of it is scripted which
you know it's it we don't script what
happens on the specials but we we are
still
you know we are we do still have that my
that voice in the back of our head that
says this is going to be content people
are going to watch this for
entertainment
because let's be real like you know
there was a part of me that was like
you know i'm sure there will be some
level of entertainment factor if
hypothetically all three of us with no
accidents whatsoever yeah
completed everything from start to
finish but you know it's the little bits
of
unexpected drama that makes for an
interesting drama it's the banter i i
feel like that's what makes for the
interesting video
i feel like part of this discussion it's
it's like we
we laugh at it because we know we didn't
take it seriously but i'm glad people
are that invested in our content
to really go balls deep to really like
break down
the levels of cheating yeah and like
okay i had like
i i swear some people could make a
spreadsheet of like every little thing
though
there's like thesis papers like the
dream cheating thing
people gonna start hiring like
astrophysicists who cheated technically
there's a one in seven trillion chance
that god's chain would break at that
very moment
there was one comment there's like why
didn't gon just put the chain back on i
did think that i was like would they go
why didn't god put the chain back
actually this wasn't uh this a lot of my
you know trying to fix the chain did get
cut out but it was like completely
lodged in there
so yeah yeah like uh the reason you were
waiting so long for us was because i was
like trying to
unlodge this [ __ ] chain and then like
i got it back on
and then it came off again immediately
and i was trying to figure out what the
[ __ ] was wrong with my bike so i had
this like
half now to 45 minutes where i realized
that
i had gone the entire cycle without
uh without first gear so so the reason
the reason the chain came off was
because when i went went to um the
highest gear it just slipped off um yeah
these bikes were very cheap and like i i
realized why i was suffering so much now
on the [ __ ] hills was because
i i was in second gear the entire way um
i also love
though how like there was so many
comments even on the video being like
oh man their seats are too low their
bikes are too small it's like
look that was the biggest bikes they had
those were the biggest bikes and i think
i did adjust my seats to be the highest
the highest
um because these people are designed for
japanese people by far
because these these we didn't buy the
bikes there were the rental bikes from
the lake
because we had a place to fly to the
other side of the country yeah so we
couldn't bring
these bikes were definitely not suited
for six foot that's for sure
speak for yourself five foot gang over
here
even but even for your size it was
smaller this just
may be okay for me but like really
pushing it like yeah yeah yeah yeah
because i remember i put my seat all the
way to the top i was like oh no this is
the highest it goes i'm gonna [ __ ]
okay we're pretty [ __ ] dumb right
yeah we're not we're not that dumb
like i saw comments that were also like
they did they even use any gears i'm
like bro you know
you wouldn't know if we didn't change
gear because god would not be moving up
anything
else yeah i think god could pedal at six
gear up a hill
i was already suffering enough on second
gear let alone [ __ ]
some people pretend like it was the
first time we ever saw a bicycle with
gears
like that day it's like what what are
these things
i didn't realize until i saw the footage
actually how much of a
how much of a clown i looked with like
this [ __ ] bike
with my massive legs just like just like
pedaling along you're basically on like
one of those like you know the kid bikes
the feet are going like over here you're
like kneeing yourself in the rib cage
every time
oh man that dude squats every time i'm
glad people enjoyed it but man
just it's not that serious guys it was
just it was just a little bit of fun
there was a lot of there was a lot of
like fluff that got cut out shout out to
mudan
for editing that and going through jesus
how much
footage like 100 hours between us
because it was like we had
the six gopros it was like one terabyte
of footage
we had six gopros for so two gopros
between each of us and then also the
handycams and whatever and the gopro in
the camera the gopro and the car as well
which is
that's why it took so long we filmed
that in october that's why
the production took so long for our next
special we
probably won't like scale up until we
have like a super super big idea maybe
try something a bit smaller you know
yeah
i feel like at this rate it's just going
to get like bigger
it's going to turn into like a mr b yeah
yeah if we don't scale back a little bit
i mean because we're the ones mainly
arranging this as well so we have to
come up with all the equipment we need
to figure everything out and so like
it's quite it's quite a lot to do it for
us like i i kind of realized this when
uh we
were doing the thing and then conor's
tyre popped and every comment was just
like
wow i can't believe they didn't plan for
like a spare tire or something like that
and
yeah in hindsight it sounds [ __ ]
stupid doesn't it
but you have to understand that most of
our planning went into
how the [ __ ] are we going to power six
gopros yeah
on our bicycles when we have one car and
none of us near each other yeah yeah so
we we were trying to figure out the
logistics of trying to get this filmed
and that's where the last thing we were
expecting was a pop-tart yeah yeah
these banks were like extra heavy
because we'd like duct tape the [ __ ] out
of stuff to it like there was like
portable batteries
strapped yeah just to like keep the
gopros right
and also gopros are such fickle things
they're amazing when they work but the
moment like there's any heat
they just stop working yeah because we
realized this during the drifting
special because
people look at this content and think
they they don't see
the [ __ ] effort and logistics that
goes into this because i didn't think
about this
until i had to go out and film yeah they
just think oh just buy some cameras and
attachments
so with with the drifting special a lot
of connor's footage just got lost yeah
so like it's a shame because like the
way when i was doing like the sick
doughnuts like
all of that footage was lost because the
gopro just overheated in like five
minutes
yeah 100 degrees yeah yeah it's an oven
in that thing and mine turned off
luckily your guys has worked i mean mine
kept dying in the second half
yeah yeah it just sucked because like
all you get to see is an outside shot it
doesn't even look like i'm in the car
doing the [ __ ] thing and you missed
all like me getting [ __ ] hyped
screaming
spoiler it was a stunt dog yeah what it
looks like it could look like a stunt
dog
so sad i'm like that's my trip that's
mine like i recently watched this horror
movie with sydney i don't remember the
name it's a korean horror movie right
but
the premise of this horror movie is that
there's this company who basically does
live stream content
right and so this company hires a bunch
of
people from the public to live stream
going into this like
haunted haunted asylum and live
streaming their experiences there
um and so i was watching this movie and
they they
they had this like jank set up with some
gopros that were apparently like live
streaming to this base camp that was
like
like a literal camp that they had set up
outside this mental asylum right
and when i was watching this i couldn't
get invested in the movie because i felt
like that guy doing like
youtuber reacts to youtuber movies right
and all i could see in the back of my
head was
they these gopros don't even have any
spare cameras [ __ ] lie there they
were like live streaming for five
hours or something like that two out of
ten not really yeah yeah there's no way
that would work
also how are they getting signal in this
mental asylum there's no way the stream
would be this
clean while they were streaming playing
inside backpacks
exactly they didn't even have the
[ __ ] 5g twitch backpacks like this is
fake movie 2 out of 10.